okay I changed my mind last minute I'm
wearing this dress it's cream uh if I
spill something on it I'm blaming all of
you let's go to the ladies look at this
beautiful creature beautiful creature
California dude what's up what's up now
perfect
professional variety started on wer real
music function life
look at the book paper yeah collectively
we all made a book except for Ken back
in beautiful beautiful Los Angeles
we're in a secret meeting from another
secret project yeah look at all these
great people Oh another hashtag secret
project actually you'll hate me because
there's so many enough tech [ __ ]
secret projects by and I've TANF retiree
I'm just wanted to give you guys a quick
announcement that I will be taking a
week off next week from making videos
you guys have inspired me to take a
break a mental health break some could
say for a week and I'll be still on
social media cuz I can't not that's a
different problem but I'll be back oh my
gosh sure it'll be better than ever
maybe no promises
that's pixie